all right we got a 2017
honda accord here i'm gonna do all lost
keys
we already have the keys cut but the
customer wants to
erase all the keys because um it says
five
keys registered and he only has uh this
one and then
the other one that i made for him so i'm
gonna delete all the keys
and then uh i'm basically gonna show you
guys the process
so put the key in ignition
[Music]
then we're going to go to all keys lost
it's already connected to the obvious
port on the car showed five keys on it
so we're gonna put
two keys to learn back
it says turn the ignition switch off
turn the ignition switch on
turn the ignition switch off so i'm just
turning the ignition
off the whole dashboard says turn the
ignition
on with the next key so now i'll take
out this key
now i'm going to put the second key in
turn the ignition on
[Music]
okay then it says turn the ignition on
and i'm gonna turn the ignition on
now i'm gonna turn the ignition on so
the dashboard lights up
turn the ignition off so i'll turn the
ignition off so the dashboard
turn the ignition on using the same key
so i'm going to turn the ignition back
on
[Music]
i'm gonna mobilize the light go out yes
there's no key light on the dashboard
so we're good to go turn the ignition
off
[Music]
turn the ignition on
the current number of keys now it's just
the two
that's it turn the ignition out
[Music]
check all keyless access for once to
make sure they work okay
that's it that's the process so i'm
gonna try to start it
with this key
car stays on doesn't cut off it's good
to go
now i'm going to try the next key factor
key
starts the card good to go everything's
good
now i'm going to check to see if the
keyless assets works
lock and unlock lock works unlock works
okay so that's good buttons all unlock
lock works
all right both the remotes functioning
correctly
and good to go if you guys have any
questions feel free
to like share subscribe and comment
peace